bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dont quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre la première audition de
la mission d'information du sénat sur
l'outre-mer de cette mission présidée
par le sénateur serge larcher auditionne
richard samuel le coordinateur des états
généraux de l'outre-mer bonne audition à
tous sur public sénat ils ont souhaité
tout de suite la bienvenue à monsieur le
délégué général et aucun d'emblée avec
mon collègue la porter et doligé au nom
de l'ensemble des élus des sénateurs de
vous présenter toutes tous nos
remerciements est revenue et de surtout
pour ouvrir les travaux de la mission au
moment qu'on est justement vos fonctions
de déléguée à l'outre-mer avec la lourde
tâche de coordonner les états généraux
il est vrai que votre connaissance des
questions ultra marines n'est plus à
démontrer bon je vous permets de
rappeler que vous avez été dans ce
domaine que la boîte à notre collègue
madame bissau lucette michaux-chevry ni
à la présidence de la régie de l'art du
conseil général la guadeloupe et que
vous avez été directeur de la sphère
politique à notre actif financière
ministère de l'outre-mer avant de
devenir le directeur de cabinet de
monsieur baroin visite au maire et c'est
là que j'osais onu avantageusement votre
histoire personnelle et les
responsabilités éminentes que vous qui
vous incombe aujourd'hui vous près des
poux dispose tout naturellement à
remettre en perspective pour nous des
événements est déroulée dans les
différents départements d'abord à la
vigne à nos boîte descend ensuite en
guadeloupe et à la martinique et tout
récemment à la réunion et je pense que
vous pouvez nous présenter votre analyse
à la suite de quoi je vous donne la
parole à ne pas reculer de dolly j je
vous remercie encore une fois
j'appuie sur le vert je voudrais
rajouter la présentation élogieuse que
vous avez fait ce sénateur
une mission dont je suis assez fier
celle d'avoir été le délégué
interministériel en charge de
l'accompagnement des familles des
victimes de la catastrophe aérienne qui
a concerné qui a frappé très durement la
martinique alors que vous dire des états
généraux que je crois que pour bien
comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
nous mettons en place cette organisation
est finalement le climat assez favorable
assez positif dans lequel les choses ont
commencé à se faire il faut rappeler
l'objectif qu'a signé le président de la
république
au sortir d'une crise qui je le rappelle
en guadeloupe a été de 44 jours en
martinique 38 jours et les jo comptent
il a été frappé par l'intensité de la
crise l'importance des de ceux qui
participaient aux manifestations la
durée de la crise et il s'est posé la
question vous le savez de savoir si un
cycle historique qui a commencé en 1946
n'était pas allée à son terme le il a
proposé aux parlementaires et des quatre
départements et aux exécutifs présidente
conseil général président de conseil
régional qu'il a reçu le 19 février de
s'engager au sortir de cette crise dans
l'intensité n'est n'est pas à rappeler
une réflexion alors vous me direz est ce
que est ce qu'une réflexion était
envisageable dans cette période là quand
on a vécu en guadeloupe en martinique en
guyane et probablement à la réunion au
cdh on sait très bien qu'au sortir des
fortes crises il y à un cyclone
tremblements de terre éruptions
volcaniques
il y à un moment de solidarité qui est
très fort et si vous me permettez
ce sénateur monsieur depuis rapporteur
je pense à un verre de saint john perse
qui est
les fortes pluies et fassent la têt tes
yeux sur l'oeil de l'homme de raison au
sortir de ces crises on a un sursaut de
solidarité on a on a du ressort si on
peut
et c'est le sentiment que j'ai eu j'ai
lorsque j'ai rencontré un goy de l'eau
pour commencer les élus les responsables
syndicaux
les responsables professionnels salariés
syndicats de salariés au tant
qu'employeur on m'a dit c'est de ce
moment de réflexion est nécessaire mais
il faut un peu de temps au sortir de la
crise et le président de la république a
accepté en quelque sorte de détendre le
calendrier puisque initialement il avait
été prévu d'engager ces travaux de
réflexion dans le courant du mois de
mars finalement ils se dérouleront du 15
avril au 15 mai les départements qui
seront les prêts à partir comment seront
les premiers et puis au fur et à mesure
nous lancerons cette réflexion dans les
départements dans lesquels les accords
ont été signés le calme est revenu
15 avril 15 mai ateliers locaux une
phase de respiration liées à la campagne
électorale des élections européennes qui
vous le savez tous ont lieu le 7 juin on
reprendrait donc les travaux dans la
semaine du 8 juin
la synthèse se ferait au niveau national
dans la dernière semaine de juin et le
un conseil interministériel sous la
présidence du président de la république
déterminerait l'aller les suites à
donner aux propositions qui ont été
faites dans la première semaine de
juillet je crois utile de rappeler même
si la presse en a fait état les thèmes
qui seront abordés pendant ces ateliers
locaux
vous savez qu'ils ont été proposées aux
élus 20 lors de la réunion du 19 au
nombre de cinq par le président lui-même
trois de ces thèmes étaient des thèmes
qui étaient directement rattachés aux
crises qui sont survenus en guadeloupe
en martinique à la réunion
le premier ne vous surprendra pas en
face d'une queue de dunes d'une grève
d'une telle durée la rénovation du
dialogue social social et la
modernisation de la formation
professionnelle rénovation du dialogue
social modernisation de la formation
professionnelle
deuxième thème lui aussi un lien évident
avec la crise intervenue aux antilles à
la réunion
la formation des prix l'organisation de
la distribution et les conséquences sur
le coût de la vie les conséquences de la
cherté de la vie en l'occurrence danser
dans ces quatre collectivités
le troisième thème lui aussi a un lien
direct
comment réduire la dépendance à l'égard
des importations
comment le thème s'appellera des voulons
développer les productions locales
endogène le quatrième thème est le thème
dont un pour lequel les collectivités
territoriales ont été très sensibles à
ce qu'il soit envisagé quels projets
structurants pour un développement
durable il est probable que dans dans
les discussions à venir
on sera amené à se poser la question est
ce que la formulation du thème au
singulier n'aurait pas été préférable à
celle d'une formulation au pluriel
quels projets structurants c'est à dire
que le projet de territoire susceptibles
d'impulser un développement durable le
cinquième thème est un thème de moyen
long terme
on a retenu la gouvernance l'institut
les cas souhaité le chef de l'état sait
quelles évolutions institutionnelles
locales et donc pas quelle évolution
statutaire comme on a souvent dans un
raccourci
posez pas quelle évolution statutaire
avec quelles évolutions
institutionnelles locales ce qui renvoie
à des tas d'autres choses que le simple
glissement de telle ou tel article de la
constitution vers tel ou tel autre mais
qui peut être une réflexion sur
l'organisation des services publics
locaux de l'état ou des collectivités
locales
la structuration intercommunale là les
conditions dans lesquelles les
collectivités locales notamment les
départements les régions assument les
compétences qu'elles d'hôtels sont dotés
au titre de l'article 73
la situation des communes qui on le sait
dans la plupart des départements
d'outre-mer est une situation délicate
les élus locaux lors de cette réunion du
19 février
on souhaitait que deux thèmes en séance
soit ajouté ces deux thèmes ne vous
surprendront pas c'est l'insertion des
départements d'outre-mer dans leur
environnement
c'est l'océan indien bassin caraïbes
l'amérique latine pour la guyane
l'autre étant l'égalité des chances la
promotion de la diversité et l'insertion
des jeunes dans les départements où le
taux de chômage des jeunes des 16 25 ans
dépasse très largement 30% après après
cette réunion il a paru souhaitable même
si le thème apparaissait comme
transversale dans ces huit ateliers dans
cet atelier est apparu souhaitable
d'ajouter un huitième qui est l'identité
la culture la mémoire il n'y aurait pas
de département d'outre-mer s'il n'y
avait pas une identité particulière
j'ai donc commencé avec le préfet de
région a engagé
la consultation une concertation avec
les exécutifs locaux qui s'y sont prêtés
de bonne grâce président du conseil
général de la guadeloupe président du
conseil régional le j'ai rencontré les
différents partis politiques que pour
représenter à l'assemblée
ou ayant une représentation locale les
responsables dans les organisations
d'employeurs un certain nombre de
représentants syndicaux et nous avons
nous sommes convenus qu'il fallait pour
que ce le souhait d'un débat sans tabou
d'un débat sans exclusive qui était ce
qui est celui du président de la
république soit respectée que ce choix
des présidents d'ateliers soit un choix
consensuel et donc mais paradoxalement
après une situation aussi le tueur peut
aussi difficile nous sommes arrivés à
retenir des présidents d'ateliers qui
fasse l'unanimité
nous avons décidé d'organiser les
ateliers avec des collèges du rapporteur
non pas un rapporteur de façon alors si
a balayé un spectre de d'opinion ou de
positionnement professionnel assez large
et nous sommes tombés d'accord assez
facilement ce qui prouve que le climat
se prête à cette réflexion le
l'organisation du travail devrait se
faire en quatre temps alors je n'ai pas
inventé le fil à couper le beurre au
fond nous avons même si on ne le sait
pas une bonne expérience de notre pays
de la démocratie participative nous
faisons de la démocratie participative
dans ce que nous appelons les grands
débats à l'occasion de deux du choix de
des plantations de nos infrastructures
centrales nucléaires j'ai moi-même été
préfet coordonnateur pour l'implantation
du site de stockage des déchets à haute
activité à vie longue
les déchets h à v achats vl de déchets
nucléaires de qui sont implantés à
stocker en longue durée et en général
nous procédons d'une manière qui est
assez assez habituel que nous avons
transposé des expériences scandinave
premier temps sur des sujets qui sont
souvent des sujets qui provoque une
émotion forte il faut un partage de
l'information il faut une mise à niveau
de l'information sur le sujet
organisation de la distribution
conséquence sur le coût de la vie même
si chacun croit avoir une idée précise
du sujet il n'est pas inutile
d'expliquer comment les feux les prix se
forment et et parfois on a des surprises
et les solutions les plus simples ne
sont pas forcément les plus évidentes
donc partage de l'information et albi
l'an état d' état zéro de la situation
deuxième temps c'est celui des
propositions
troisième temps synthèse et probablement
il pourrait y avoir un quatrième temps
si les collectivités locales décidé de
s'emparer de la réflexion tandis de la
validation et je crois qu'il serait pas
inintéressant que dans le dossier remis
au président en vue de du conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer qu'il y
ait une délibération des comités
économiques et sociaux du conseil de la
culture de l'éducation de
l'environnement ou le cas échéant des
assemblées des assemblées locales ou de
l'assemblée des maires des des
compagnies consulaires
voilà pour ce qui concerne
l'organisation le président a souhaité
en outre que ce soit un débat très
largement ouvert et il a souhaité
notamment que ce soit le débat le plus
plus important qui était jamais organisé
un autre maire nous pour atteindre cet
objectif nous aurons en quelque sorte
3,3 cible la première il y aura un site
internet de mise en place
plan national et nous veillons à ce que
les contributions reçues soit largement
diffusée vers les départements
ce site a déjà commencé à fonctionner
sous la forme d'un site d'un teasing
d'un site de présentation dans la
semaine il deviendra un site contributif
et avant le 15 avril ce sera un site
interactif c'est à dire que nous
recevons des contributions il pourrait y
avoir des réponses
pourquoi et c'est pourquoi est-ce que je
commence par le site le site internet
parce que me dit on les réunionnais et
les antillo-guyanais participe
énormément à la blogosphère me dit que
pendant la crise que nous avons
traversée
il y a eu environ 300000 contribution
sur internet de réunionnais et il y a
plus de 600000 contribution lentilles
donc une participation
on pourrait presque dire que c'est nous
prendrons en charge la la contribution
du 6e département si on considère que
depuis dimanche il ya il ya un cinquième
qui n'est pas seulement les antillais
vivant dans l'hexagone
deuxième chose j'ai provoqué une réunion
des directeurs de stations radio
télévision la presse écrite directeur et
rédacteur en chef pour leur proposer que
la presse s'associe très largement à ce
débat civique et j'ai la certitude
qu'ils nous proposeront des émissions un
peu du type de celles qu'ils font en
général dans l'hexagone ou en outre-mer
à l'occasion de faits divers un peu
d'autres on parle des émissions où nous
prêterons des rapporteurs des présidents
d'ateliers et les
un animateur journaliste lancera le
thème l'expliquera et puis fera appel
aux contributions du public
nous nous aurons troisièmement avec
l'aide des recteurs une association
assez large à ce qui doit être un débat
civique des élèves de lycée et des
élèves de collège
je crois raisonnable de penser que les
huit ateliers peuvent être faire l'objet
d'un examen dans l'est dans les lycées
et en revanche nous proposerons que dans
les collèges
il y ait au moins deux des thèmes qui
seraient examinées par exemple logique
que des garçons et les filles de 12 à 2
10 à 16 ans et réfléchi sur les
questions d'identité de culture et de
mémoire
de même qui paraît logique que des
garçons de 10 modifié de 10 à 16 ans et
réfléchi sur les questions de
développement durable
voilà à peu près les conditions dans
lesquelles nous chercherons à viser un
large public et je sais bien et nous
savons bien ici à quel point la radio
joue un rôle important dans la lah
boration de l'opinion générale nous nous
appuierons très fortement sur les radios
ainsi que sur le site internet visant
par là même des publics un peu un peu
différent je voudrais conclure ce
premier point mais monsieur le sénateur
en disant une chose c'est que non
seulement nous rechercherons cette
participation du public
mais il faut bien se rappeler que parce
qu'on a à répondre à une question
compte tenu du délai est ce que vous
prendrez bien un compte
est-ce que vous aurez le temps de faire
des propositions qui seront qui au fond
seront des réponses à cette crise grave
que nous avons connue et deuxièmement la
deuxième question qui nous est posée
est-ce que vous avez des raisons
raisonnables de penser que une suite
pratique sera donnée aux propositions
qui seront faites sur le deuxième point
je voudrais insister sur une chose les
propositions seront prises en compte par
un conseil interministériel de
l'outre-mer la structure administrative
aux intérêts de ministres et yves la
plus proche du conseil interministériel
est
que nous connaissons tous probablement
c'est le siat conseil interministériel
d'aménagement et de développement du
territoire
nous avons là l'opportunité de voir les
questions de l'autre mère prise en
compte par un conseil présidé par le
président de la république lui-même
entouré
entouré du premier ministre et de
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
ça veut dire que le sujet de notre nez à
la crise que nous venons de connaître et
prise en compte personnellement il faut
savoir aussi que conseil
interministériel
c'est une structure qui se prépare très
dangereux comme s'il y avait des gens d
administration dans cette salle ils vous
diront que le siat ça se prépare
deux trois mois à l'avancé toute
l'administration parce que le président
la république préside le conseil
interministériel est mobilisé et lors du
conseil le président au fond donne une
feuille de route aux ministres concernés
c'est-à-dire en clair des objectifs et
un calendrier et le conseil suivant est
l'occasion pour lui de faire le point
sur les suites données le respect en
quelque sorte de la feuille de route par
les ministres ou les ministères sur le
point qui consiste à dire au fond nous
manqueront temps pour prendre en compte
les propositions qui sont susceptibles
d'apporter des réponses pertinentes aux
questions qui ont été posées pendant ces
quarante quatre jours où ses 38 jours
je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait une claire
conscience de ce que les sujets qui ont
fait l'objet de difficultés sont pas des
suggéré sans que la question de du de la
cherté de la vie dans ces quatre
départements nous n'allons pas les
découvrir des réflexions ont été
conduites et sont relativement
importantes sur ces sujets là la
question de la dépendance à l'égard des
importations leur si nous n'allons pas
découvrir la question des réponses ont
été élaborées depuis un certain temps et
là l'opportunité ou la l'obligation dans
laquelle nous serons ça n'est pas de
recueillir dans les différents rapports
ou dans les différentes document de
planification qui ont été élaborées par
les collectivités locales conseils
régionaux conseils généraux se serait
d'arriver
à transformer ses propositions en projet
collectif en projet partagé par une
large fraction de ce kilo qui les ont
élaborées ou qui auront à les mettre en
oeuvre
en un mot en un mot arriver à un projet
collectif et ce sera la difficulté à
laquelle n'ont pas moi mais les
présidents d'ateliers les rapporteurs
seront confrontés parce que la question
qui dit qui nous sera posée à l'occasion
et qui sera une réponse à tel ou tel
refrain qui a été entonné pendant ces
événements c'est que voulons nous que
voulons nous pour nous sentir à l'aise
dans l'espace républicain espace
républicain qui n'est pas simplement une
île mais qui est probablement la
combinaison entre territoires une
histoire et les valeurs et parfois
pendant ces crises ces valeurs ont pu
être oubliés
voilà monsieur président en quelques
mots ce que je peux vous dire sur la
préparation de ces états généraux
très bien je vous remercie monsieur le
président je devais général sur le
dernier râle pour propos très clairs
j'observe que que vous avez dit je pense
que c'est pas lapsus que voulons-nous
donc que vous incluez dans le nous je
leur ai mauvaises graisses le fait très
bien bien mes chers collègues
quelqu'un peut-il intervenir monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le président ce
délégué général le plaisir de vous
retrouver dans ses fonctions puisque
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de vous
auditionné dans un autre cadre
d'abord vous a confié une mission
importante et nous avons également
constituer une mission qui est
importante et l'objectif bien sûr de nos
travaux c'est de travailler en
coordination en participation de
s'enrichir et de pas s'affaiblir donc de
trouver les voies et les moyens pour
travailler 1
elie jamais ensemble et en
complémentarité alors j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les les cinq grandes
pistes que vous avez évoquées et puis
les sujets qui sont venus s'additionner
j'avais un certain nombre de questions à
vous poser vous avez déjà répondu à une
bonne partie concernant donc le
calendrier la méthodologie les
différents sujets que vous alliez traité
dans un temps court mais nous vivons
dans le même temps un temps également
extrêmement court nous avons également
l'intention de faire un certain nombre
de propositions et nous pensons que ces
propositions seront entendus au moment
du comité interministériel qu'elles
pourront venir compléter et enrichir les
travaux que vous aurez pu mener dans le
cadre des états généraux
alors je vais prendre que quelques unes
des questions quelques uns des thèmes
ce qui nous intéresse également enfin
d'abord c'est bien sûr ne pas reprendre
exactement ce que vous faites beaucoup
je crois qu'on est bien en
complémentarité
la situation financière et budgétaire
des collectivités territoriales
ultramarines nous semble quelque chose
extrêmement important dans le cadre du
fonctionnement des départements
d'outre-mer et on a pu entendre dans le
débat le des hommes toutes les
inquiétudes des élus sur le financement
de leur collectivité sur la disparition
à terme l'octroi de mer donc là certains
qui les interpelle donc nous avons
l'intention de travailler sur ce sujet
alors je vais vous poser la question est
ce un des sujets que vous allez aborder
alors vous allez me dire oui ou non et
comment ensuite sur le problème de la
formation des prix donc on l'a évoqué
entre nous c'était pas et des sujets
qu'on avait retenu a priori en tant que
tel on avait retenu plus ce qui
concernait l'évaluation et la continuité
territoriale dans la continuité
territoriale
il ya bien sûr une évaluation également
des prix des prix de transport plus
particulièrement
mais en ce qui concerne
l'évaluation c'est un sujet qui nous
paraît extrêmement important et nous
avons le sentiment qu'il y à peu
d'évaluation des politiques publiques ou
qu'on a quelques difficultés lorsque
l'on débat entre nous pour connaître les
vrais chiffres
l'autre évaluation et contrôle donc qui
est un sujet sur lequel on travaillait
donc je voulais avoir votre sentiment
sur ce sujet et voir la complémentarité
avec la formation des prix ensuite sur
les jeunes mais je pense que là nous
avons une réflexion commune sur le sujet
nous le verrons peut-être plus
particulièrement dans le cadre de la
vision de la jeunesse clé de l'avenir au
niveau des départements d'outre-mer avec
également tout ce qui est lié à la
formation des jeunes
et puis enfin nous pensons qu'il y à une
réflexion intéressante à faire sur la
gouvernance alors vous l'avez également
également cités mais nous pensons que
cela peut aller également dans tout ce
qui concerne la situation financière des
collectivités de réfléchir à l'intérieur
de ce thème sur la gouvernance elle qui
est souhaitée celle qui est souhaitable
ou celle éventuellement qu'il faudrait
mettre en oeuvre à la demande des des
ultramarins concernant l'avenir des
territoires
voilà quelques quelques sujets je vous
donne simplement très rapidement les les
autres sujets l'autre la situation
financière j'aurais parlé la continuité
territoriale
donc je vous en ai parlé mais c'est
l'insertion régionale qui nous paraît
extrêmement importante
les jeunes on en a parlé l'évaluation et
le contrôle sujet qui nous paraissent
importants et enfin dans le cadre vous
l'avez dit plus à l'heure du
développement de gênes nous pensons le
regarde et plus particulièrement au
travers de l'environnement alors la
décollecte nous en reparlerons ils ont
parlé de l'information du prix bien sûr
ils ont parlé du foncier ils ont parlé
du logement qui sont des vrais soucis et
des vraies inquiétudes
donc si vous avez sur ces points là
également
des interventions ou des thèmes qui
doivent être pris dans vos ateliers
merci de vouloir préciser je vous
rappellerai simplement que je souhaite
qu'on puisse avoir une relation
permanente de manière à ne pas se
trouver les uns par rapport aux autres à
cheminer sur des sentiers totalement
identiques ou voir à questionner les
personnes totalement identique pour bien
faire en sorte que nos travaux soient
complémentaires qui veut dernier madame
gildas merci président je préfère je
puisse un jour préfet ou délégué général
ça revient au même
selon mes chers collègues les événements
qui se sont produits dans nos
départements respectifs montre la
gravité de la situation sociale dans les
dom
ils montrent aussi et tout le monde l'a
souligné les limites d'une politique
menée jusqu'à présent dans les
départements d'outre-mer et vous venez
un instant même de l'e book est aussi le
président de la république et le
gouvernement tire raison de proposer une
remise à plat de toutes ces politiques à
travers les états généraux qui se
dérouleront ce mois ci rochât dans les
dépenses en français d'amérique et à la
réunion en attendant ses résultats des
résultats de ces états généraux des
mesures d'urgence se sont avérés
nécessaires pour donner confiance aux
populations les plus défavorisées et
surtout pour leur venir en aide
rapidement
c'est ainsi que des accords ont été
signés en guadeloupe et en martinique le
mois dernier alors je souhaite pour dire
un petit peu ce qui se passe chez nous
qui continue qui s'est passé à la
réunion sous l'impulsion du comité d
organisation
syndicales politiques et associatives
dénommé le cospar des avancées
importantes ont été enregistrées baisse
de 5 à 20% des prix de 250 produits
l'accord a été signé et on a fait plus
vite que la loi puisque la lodeom n'est
pas encore finie j'aime des loyers
ramener à leurs niveaux du 31 décembre
2008 baisse des prix des services
bancaires de 10 à 15% et à cela il faut
ajouter une baisse des carburants et du
gaz obtenu dès le début du mouvement
ce sont donc des acquis positifs et
après c'est comme tel par l'opinion
reste de problème cependant qu'ils n'ont
pas encore été solutionné ce qui fait
qu'un accord global n'a pas été signé
jusqu'à ce jour ce sont les minima
sociaux et les salaires et tout à
l'heure nous avons un peu évoqué réunion
à propos des salles et à le cospar a
fait une proposition qui part du constat
suivant une augmentation de 150 euros
des bas salaires inférieurs à 1,4 smic
avec une intervention de l'état par le
biais du est restée à 200 euros
donc il est 50 euros à la charge de
l'entreprise quelle que soit la taille
de celle ci grosses moyennes et petites
ou petites
or les petites et moyennes entreprises
les petits et moyennes entreprises et
les très petites entreprises ont fait
savoir dès le début qu'elle n'avait pas
les moyens de supporter ces charges
supplémentaires d'où la proposition du
cospar de moduler l'aide de l'état
habite à budget constant - 200 euros
pour les salariés de grands entreprises
qui participeraient à plus de 50 euros
et plus de 100 euros pour ceux des
petites entreprises qui elles
participeraient à moins de 50 euros
c'est en quelque sorte constituer un
fonds de réserve de réguler les salaires
cette proposition qui à ma connaissance
n'a pas été rejetée par le patronat
local à l'avant l'avantagent de faire
jouer la solidarité des trois
entreprises lui au verdict de glisse
tout en permettant tous les travailleurs
à bas revenus de bénéficier de la même
augmentation de 150 euros par mois
je ne comprends pas pourquoi l'état a
refusé un tel accord je me permets de
poser cette question aujourd'hui puisque
nous parlons des états généraux nous
parlons des minima sociaux nous parlons
car c'est une proposition réunionnaise à
une situation réunionnaise je reste
toujours dans le cadre de même pour les
minima sociaux et bosses d'étudiants
vouloir imposer l'accord bino à la
réunion comme ça a été dit n'a aucun
sens dans la mesure où la situation
réunionnaise est différent de celle de
la guadeloupe c'est je pense aussi
l'état d'esprit des états généraux
l'état ne pourrait-il pas revenir sur sa
position
si tel était le cas alors un accord
global est encore possible à la réunion
ce qui créerait à mon sens les
meilleures conditions possibles pour le
bon déroulement des états généraux
ensuite tous les thèmes que vous avez
avancé et rajouter à 20 vrai j'aimerais
évidemment ça va dans le sens que nous
souhaitons
mais j'aimerais souligner un thème qui
me fait tous les thèmes sont très
importants et me font plaisir d'en
discuter pour aller au fond des choses
comme le souhaite le président de la
république
après tout ce qui s'est passé et toutes
les populations ultramarines
alors il ya un thème que je vais relever
c'est l'identité la culture la mémoire
et je souhaite dire oui je fais vite je
souhaite dire là que peut-être justement
en abordant ce thème à travers les états
généraux à la réunion ce sera enfin la
polémique autour de la maison des
civilisations et de l'unité réunionnaise
pour qu'enfin peut-être nos jeunes
élèves qui sont à l'école vont apprendre
qu ils sont mêmes pour beaucoup
d'adultes beaucoup règne de réunionnais
savoie enfin comment a été fait comment
été créé le peuple réunionnais c'est à
dire de la rencontre c'est dans la
souffrance et tout ce qu'on connaît de
l'histoire comment c'est fait c'est
l'histoire mais loin de la rencontre de
les quatre continents
voilà en tout cas ça m'a fait très
plaisir d'aborder ce thème merci à ben
mais nous irons certainement bilitis et
de maison des civilisations certainement
d'autant plus a eu un avis favorable
déjà du rapporteur de l'enquêteur ce qui
me choque c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
choses à voir et à examiner par monsieur
je suis rapporteur ce président vous me
passez la parole avec un sourire que je
déchiffre la question madame le sénateur
vous le savez bien ne va pas au délégué
général et lorsque terres d'état à
l'outre-mer lorsqu'il s'agit de savoir
si l'on peut envisager que la au fond le
la formule que nous avons retenu des la
guadeloupe pour pouvoir trouver une
solution rapide à la crise et répondre à
la demande d'augmentation des salaires
notamment des bas salaires a été
d'anticiper un dispositif que je connais
bien comme préfet puisqu'il et j'ai été
un des prétextes limandas temps
expérimentateur qui s'appelle le revenu
de solidarité active le rsa
nous avons donc anticipé et mis en place
un dispositif particulier qui
s'appellera momentanément pour une
période donnée est resté à mai la
modularité en fonction de la taille de
l'entreprise n'est pas envisageable
puisque c'est un droit un droit légal
une prestation légal qui sera offert à
ceux qui rempliront les conditions
posées par la loi la solution paraît
effectivement simple à proposer je vous
dirais sous forme de boutade
est-ce qu'il est surprenant que les
employeurs le patronat ait été favorable
à la demande
ils ne paient pas en l'occurrence et
c'est l'état qui paie donc qu'il est en
l'occurrence ils ont ils ont à se
déterminer sur leur contribution à eux
pas forcément sur les conditions de mise
en place de la prestation égale je crois
qu'elle a fait l'objet d'un examen le
plus bienveillant possible et dans
l'état actuel des choses il paraît
difficile d'envisager une formule
dérogatoire du type de celle que vous
souhaitez ou du type de celle qui a été
demandée par le collectif le cospar
je vous rappelle qu'il reste un petit
quart d'heure alors je pense à paroles
souvent assez bien les questions à
georges le patient c'est la pire de la
guyane de deux petites questions je vais
te rapide
la première je voudrais que vous me
donniez l'assurance que les propositions
qui vont remonter qu'ils vont être issus
de ces états généraux vont aboutir sur
des solutions propres à chaque
département depuis toujours on associe
la martinique la guyane la guadeloupe et
la réunion
c'était les quatre vieilles précités les
quatre départements d'outre-mer la
lodeom dû se battre pour qu'on reconnaît
quelques petits spécificité à la guyane
donc là on va travailler sur les états
généraux
mais audrey avoir l'assurance qu'après
il sortira pas un moule unique pour les
quatre dom je ne cesse de le répéter la
guyane est bien particulière et sur le
continent
là d'autres problèmes que les îles
rien n'est pas une île ça c'était le
premier point deuxième question depuis
quelques temps en guyane mais je crois
en martinique aussi se pose est est
rouvert le dossier sur l'évolution
statutaire en guyane en est très avancé
un débat public
les états généraux interviennent en
plein milieu de ce débat public est tout
à leur avait laissé entendre que la vie
la façon de voir les choses du président
était plutôt sur une organisation
institutionnelle bon est ce que ce n'est
pas une façon un petit peu pernicieuse
déjà de se positionner au niveau de la
question qui va être posée aux huit
années au martiniquais en parlant d'
organisation institutionnelle est ce
qu'on fait pas déjà référence à des
propositions type commission balladur
tu crois vraiment pas pourquoi le fait
d'avoir dit institutionnels pourraient
renvoyer à une au travaux d'une
commission particulière le terme
institutions renvoie au contraire à la
plus large acceptation que nous
puissions avoir de l'organisation thw
administratif sur politique de notre
pays
wipro les maths et rendre nos images en
l'occurrence j'ai rappelé que nous
avions la possibilité
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'organisation
institutionnelle de balayer un spectre
assez large
nous allons nous poser parmi les sujets
communs la question de la cherté de la
vie dans les quatre départements
personne ne peut nier que c'est un sujet
comme un site un sujet commun qui
appellera probablement des dispositifs
de politiques publiques adaptées à
chacune et à chacun des départements
mais il est probable que le moule
normatif houleux où la décision de
politique publique concernera
presqu'autant lag la guyane la
martinique la guadeloupe et la réunion
les questions de tarification du
carburant les questions d'organisation
de la distribution puisque au fond même
les comme même les collectivités
d'outre-mer même celles qui sont passés
à l'article 74 ont cette question
pendant la cherté de la vie
elle est aussi réelle en polynésie et
les réels en saint pierre et miquelon
qui dépendent de l'article 74 et le
dispositif envisagé sera un dispositif
qui aura un tronc commun probablement
sur sur la question des délits des
réponses qui seront adaptés à chacun des
départements
au fond vous avez déjà la réponse au
sénat puisque je me souviens que
certains d'entre vous ont fait adopter
lors de l'examen de la lodeom en
première lecture chez vous une
modification de l'intitulé je crois que
vous étiez un de ce monsieur sénateurs
qui ont fait cette proposition qui a été
m
vous avez vous avez fait cette
proposition et qui a été je crois voté à
une très large majorité
je crois que c'est bien limité je
voudrais pas le dire par votre assemblée
de but
et prendre en compte qu'il n'y avait pas
un autre maire mais d autres mr jalel
nous nous soyons convaincus que nous
avons retenu la proposition et que la
démarche sera la nôtre
je voudrais juste ajouter une chose non
ma mission ne sera pas de proposer ou de
dire ce qui sera à faire mais de
recueillir avec des présidents
d'ateliers des rapporteurs
les propositions qui viendront des
ateliers locaux et vous verrez que pour
ce qui a été fait en guadeloupe pour ce
qui a été fait en martinique
nous avons fait le choix d'avoir des
présidents d'ateliers des rapporteurs
qui soit qui viennent nous n'avons pas
exclu
les élus une dose de rapporteur deux
présidents d'ateliers sont d une
parlementaire l'autre un ancien député
européen maire en guadeloupe en
martinique nous avons un certain nombre
de propositions les choses ne sont pas
arrêtées qui intégreront des élus de
première responsabilité mais nous avons
fait un large appel à la société civile
aux professionnels ou chefs d'entreprise
aux syndicalistes sur un sujet comme le
dialogue social il est évident qu'il
nous faut avoir des syndicalistes et des
responsables patronaux pour bien
réfléchir et travailler et avoir des
propos propositions concrètes donc les
propositions qui seront faites seront
celles des guadeloupéens des
martiniquais et des guyanais et
réunionnais en réponse à la question
proposé que proposez vous pour rendre
l'espace républicain plus plus agréable
à vivre que est en quelque sorte gommer
les essais les insatisfactions que nous
avons connue sur la période écoulée très
bien ce sera sans tabou par conséquent
chez un collègue mais le problème n'est
pas épuisé beau temps si les élus
proposent une évolution situationnelle
de cas de l'article 74 et que l'état
vidéo
ils sont les airs et des eaux une
évolution d'afrique de 413,5 l'activité
unique la pause envol en difficulté je
le veux non je crois
la martinique est dans une réflexion
conduite à peu près au même rythme que
la guyane hypothèse d'école bien sûr je
ne fais ni rancune toute l'activité et
je crois que la martinique où je parle
sous votre contrôle a délibéré en
congrès le 18 décembre a fait et
envisage de délibérer en congrès
prochainement
mais les échanges que j'ai eus avec les
deux exécutifs m'a laissé penser qu'il
avait bien cerné les étapes que la
procédure constitutionnelle leur impose
aux liens de ces étapes c'est la
décision de principe si on peut dire
mais la deuxième étape c'est quelles
sont les compétences que les
collectivités locales souhaitent voir
exercer au plan local
il faut que nous ayons tous en tête
qu'il n'y a pas un statut d'une
collectivité relevant de l'article 74
qui ressemble à un autre
le statut de saint martin n'est pas
celui de saint barthélémy ça n'est pas
non plus celui de la laddh de la
polynésie le statut de saint pierre et
miquelon est différent et par conséquent
probablement avant de faire ce saut vers
le 74 il faut se poser la question quel
projet de territoire on a en tête que
des responsabilités exercées au plan
local permettront 9,2 de mettre en
oeuvre de manière efficace et flea et
puis vous le savez une fois ces deux
étapes franchies il y en a une troisième
le peuple d'abord d'en saisir l'exécutif
troisième étape
et puis il y en a une quatrième que là
aussi on ne peut pas contourner quand ce
que c'est la consultation des
populations
donc c'est lorsque ces quatre étapes
sont franchies que l'on peut ensuite se
dire alors est-ce que l'une de ses
étapes peut-être longtemps contrarié par
une réflexion qui ensuite de toute façon
est prise en charge par l'exécutif je
laisse à votre sagesse qui souhaitent de
de répondre et aux rapports que vous
ferez mais j'ai pas de doute sur votre
compte et plus que je vous remercie
un trône est sénateur de la guyane merci
non je voulais pas vous couper la parole
tout à l'heure je voulais simplement
m'inscrire pour poser ma question je
rentrais pas dans le débat dans le fond
parce que nous sommes et sur la méthode
et les objectifs alors sur la méthode du
juste une question vous ai dit que ces
débats se rendant que relier par les
médias etc
mais l'école dans les écoles j'ai en
mémoire donc les assises du
développement qui avait été menée par
madame gérard dhesse que ça prendra
cette forme
j'ai une grande salle lorsque le public
que le public sera présent alors ça
c'est la première question
donc c'est la méthode maintenant chanson
le fond je crois qu on pourrait
également ajouter un autre thème à
savoir quelle est la stratégie de l'état
par rapport aux départements d'outre-mer
très souvent nous y en cas de crise
dites nous ce que vous voulez on va
essayer d'une traduction juridique ou
politique mais je crois que il est bon
aussi
dans le cadre de ces états généraux que
lui l'état nous dise très précisément
quelle est sa stratégie
quel rôle à titre d'exemple que pourrait
jouer la guyane sur le continent sud
américain
quel est le rôle comment la guyane qui
est le port spatial de l'europe qui va
être maintenant mise à la disposition de
l'union européenne on peut dire la même
chose aussi des antilles autour de la
caraïbe et de la réunion autour de la
paix du pacifique
je crois que c'est l'occasion aussi me
semble-t-il que l'état parce qu'on va
construire votre avenir on va construire
demain dans une phase de contradiction
et de dianétique mais il faut entier
déjà que l'état s'il ya une stratégie
nous dise quelle est sa stratégie
s'il ya bien une stratégie
trèbes est une question qui ressemble
mais c'est pour permettre aux délégués
justement de gagner du temps deux
questions de première manche quoique
effectivement ces états généraux c'est
un moment important un pour nos
territoires nous l'avons dit tout
mouvement transitoire mais pas autant
monsieur le délégué le retour que nous
avons aujourd'hui c'est que vu le temps
qui nous est imparti un mois ont créé
que ce débat-là ne s'en tiennent qu'à un
débat d'experts et nous avons parlé vous
l'avez vous avez dit ça ensemble nous
avions dit que c'était on doit avoir un
projet collectif
alors je me pose la question est ce que
il faut pas encore faire un effort c'est
une demande et même eux seraient encore
une efforts beaucoup plus importants
pour que cette population le citoyen
soit effectivement impliqué dans ces
états généraux c'est important parce
qu'en fait nous avons déjà commencé ces
états généraux
deuxièmement je crois qui fait que l'on
sait pas encore c'est une demande mais
en fait c'est une demande de dit que les
étasuniens ont commencé suite à la mise
en place des présents présidents et des
rapporteurs
ils ont commencé à travailler sur le
terrain jouent et souhaité qu' ici que
nous soyons un un atelier pour dire et
je rejoins le jusqu'à jurer que le
collègue loger les 10 le pré sident de
l'accompagnement des collectivités
locales souhaitent effectivement à ce
coup qu'elles ont reçu déjà déjà les les
difficultés qu'elles ont et suite à ces
à cette crise you elles doivent répondre
à cette onde de contraintes notamment le
point de quota horaire bref un sait-on
de deux charges qui interviennent après
la crise est ce que nous ne pouvions pas
dire aujourd'hui si les collections
d'accorder dit qu'effectivement nous
pensions que ces états généraux doivent
pouvoir dire que les collectivités
droits pour bénéficier d'un abonnement
de leur dgf si on peut dire ça pour
opérer de répondre à ces à ces contrées
plage os x c'est un choix je sais pas si
le délégué pourrait déjà prendre ça en
place de dicko au sénat lors de
l'audition les collègues unanimement je
pense que virapoullé tués
dans le sens de dire que nous voulons qu
effectivement qui est une prise en
charge d'une d'un abonnement plus
important d'agir
c'est une proposition en même temps je
pense les fautes croquerait sur les
reggae vous n'êtes pas fait c'est pas
lui qui fait il là il est agent
coordonnateur jouer souhaitait
sincèrement qu'on puisse profiter de
notre présence pour le dire voilà ce que
je dis je sais pas si c'est possible je
vous donne d'abord à votre 3 net sous la
stratégie de l'état ensuite on se voit
sur l'intervention de régis l'eau
mission de reconnaître le cnt en prenait
pas posé de questions la première est ce
que dans la méthode nous serons dans un
dispositif une organisation qui
ressemble un peu aux assises du
développement local
je leur répondrais très simplement et
rapidement le président a souhaité que
nous allions très au delà 12,7 ce
concours en quelque sorte de déco
d'amplification que nous recherchons
internet les écoles les lycées les
stations de radio télévision la presse
écrite de façon à ce que au sortir de
cette période d'effervescence qui a été
très importante en guadeloupe qu'en
martinique et à la réunion que les
réponses de long terme
réponse de long terme que l'on cherche
soit réponse qui soit connu de l'opinion
qu'elle participe à quelque sorte à
cette réflexion collective même si tout
le monde ne peut pas être présent sur la
stratégie de l'état je me répéte ray
mond ma mission est de faire émerger en
offrant la parole à la société civile
société politique comprise la
possibilité sur un certain nombre de
thèmes qui ont été retenus élaboré en
commun avec les grands élus de dire au
fond ce que le territoire concerné
souhaite pour que ses habitants se
sentent plus à l'aise dans l'espace
républicain
la stratégie de l'état est d'abord celle
là c'est d'aller rechercher cette ses
propositions cette contribution de
nature à apaiser la les conditions dans
lesquelles nous vivons dans l'espace
républicain et je le répète ça n'est pas
simplement en l'occurrence une île en
département
c'est tout l'espace républicain avec
notre citoyenneté européenne
et c'est une histoire et en même temps
que des valeurs liberté égalité
fraternité parmi d'autres donc nous
n'allons pas dire ce que ce qu'il faut
faire
nous demandons aujourd'hui de chercher à
élaborer à faire converger un projet
collectif qui vient du territoire les
technocrates européens dirait bottom up
de la base vers le sommet avec au fond
une attention particulière de l'état au
sortir de cette crise
pourquoi est-ce que le temps n'est pas
trop court j'étais préfète de l'eure
jusqu'à une semaine jusqu'au 30
j'étais au moment de la crise la plus
profonde dans un comité d'établissement
qui était celui de glaxo une entreprise
pharmaceutique 2000 salariés à côté
d'une ville de 50000 habitants qui
evreux j'étais là pour dire aux salariés
que les services de l'état
accompagnerait le plan de sauvegarde et
leur difficulté de la manière la plus
active possible parce que glaxo fait des
bénéfices mais l'axoa annoncé un plan de
sauvegarde de 796 licenciements sur 2000
salariés
ceci pour dire que si nous ne profitons
pas de cet instant d'attention fort de
l'opinion si nous retardons trop le
moment des propositions nous n'aurons
pas la même écoute bienveillante de la
part de l'opinion publique parce que
nous sommes tous conscients de ce que le
pays s'enfonce dans une crise très grave
et que du fait des délais le plan de
relance n'a pas commencé à produire de
manière tout à fait net
comme on pouvait s'y attendre ses effets
donc il faut que nous profitions de ce
délai ou l'opinion publique a le
sentiment qu'il ya une crise très grave
très profonde et que nous puissions
demander que certains nombres de nos
propositions soient prises en compte sur
la proposition du président gillot de
large participation j'ai essayé d'y
répondre en même temps que j'avais pendu
aux sénateurs de la guyane sur le fait
que le débat que nous souhaitons n'est
pas un débat avec qui peut se comparer à
tel ou tel autre c'est un débat qui est
souhaitée sans précédent avec une large
participation des populations sur la
proposition qu'il fait que d'ores et
déjà
on puisse tenir compte de la situation
des collectivités locales je crois que
nous aurons du mal à éviter que ça soit
dans le champ de la réflexion sauf si
elles étaient restreintes uniquement au
débat statutaire ce que je ne crois pas
compte tenu de la qualité des
participantes que nous avons déjà
commencé à mobiliser en guadeloupe et il
le sait et je le remercie d'avoir
contribué à faire que au sortir de cette
période de difficultés importantes très
rapidement avec lui avec le président du
conseil régional avec les parlementaires
avec les responsables professionnels
nous avons pu rapidement lancé ces états
généraux à la guadeloupe et il a raison
de dire que depuis le début de la
semaine les choses sont lancées puisque
les présidents d'ateliers et les
rapporteurs ont commencé à travailler
monsieur général je crois que pour
compléter la question de mon collègue
antoine est ce qui vous êtes dire c'est
qu'est ce que nous aurions encore des
grand messes dans les 30 salle jean
marie anna à la martinique ou bien si
nous aurions des réunions
décentralisation dans les communes de
partout c'est ça c'est bien je traduis
jetta à penser ça je peux répondre sur
ce point que en guadeloupe il la
situation l'archipel appellera que nous
ayons des réunions délocalisées dans les
îles
on verra
une d une des responsables en charge de
l'atelier qui traitera des questions de
l'égalité des chances de d de promotion
de la diversité et l'insertion des
jeunes me disais que si on un tel sujet
il faudra aller dans les îles du sud où
les questions une acuité importante
en martinique il des problèmes que nous
n'avons pas une situation de l'archipel
il faudra aller au moins au moins jeudi
vient au moins mais ça dépendra aussi de
ce que les rapporteurs les présidents
d'ateliers souhaiteront au moins aller
dans les trois arrondissements
c'est qui ce sera un minimum je crois
que les principaux élus en martinique
nous ont déjà fait savoir qu'ils
souhaiteront de leur propre chef
organiser des réunions ils m'ont
abandonné le terme créole qu'ils
utiliseront ces très imagé régira la
javel elle préfère les l'exposé mais la
formule sera très imagé elle parlera
beaucoup en guyane il était je vous
savez je serai en guyane vendredi après
midi
j'ai donc une série de réunions et je
crois que je rencontrerai les sénateurs
puisque les députés provenant sont
absents mais je crois qu'entre les
sénateurs pour évoquer dans le détail
les conditions d'organisation vous mais
très probablement en tout cas je le
souhaite à tenir compte de l'immensité
du territoire de guyanais qui représente
à lui tout seul d'une bonne vingtaine de
départements métropolitains et donc si
nous voulons réellement atteindre
l'objectif de large participation nous
serons conduits à nous poser la question
en dehors de cayenne ou devons-nous
aller et je compte beaucoup sur votre
connaissance du territoire pour que nous
puissions faire des choix pas pertinent
de localisation et que nous varions les
délocalisations en fonction des thèmes
qui vous paraîtrait correspondre à des
besoins et à dissuader attention
particulière des parties du département
de la guyane
merci chers collègues doive de mille
cinq minutes à peu près pour rattraper
le retard et à l'épaule ou du parent je
passe la parole à mon collègue
et rappelez de la réunion merci
présidence je préfère nous avons plaisir
de vous retrouver
le menu est copieux huit questions qui
bien sûr en concluant l'agrément au
général mal l'observation de fond que je
voudrais faire c'est de dire que nous
avons avec ces états généraux qui ont
suscité un espoir dans les départements
d'outre-mer un espoir réel
rendez vous avec notre avenir et
l'expérience que j'ai de ma vie pas
d'élus de parlementaire et peut-être
pour beaucoup d'entre nous c'est que
outre mer
nous traitons les problèmes à chaud et
souvent nous traitons les problèmes dans
leurs conséquences
mais pas dans leur cause et lorsque le
chef de l'état a annoncé les états
généraux je me suis dit c'est peut-être
l'occasion de changer de cap de changer
de méthode de petr ne pas faire de ces
états généraux
le recensement des revendications
catégorielles qui débouche
obligatoirement sur toujours plus de
moyens
il en faudra probablement comme un
dictateur mon collègue sénateur de la
guadeloupe
mais je voudrais voulu avoir votre
sentiment sur le fait que cette fois ci
nous nous attaquions aux causes des huit
questions que vous avez soulevé cause
par exemple pour quelles raisons
profondes et réellement analyser c'est à
dire analyser de façon contradictoire
le coût de la vie est plus chère
outre-mer n'aurais pas pu n'aurait-on
pas pu faire autrement par des
approvisionnements régionaux n'aurait
pas inscrit aujourd'hui je le sais mais
on va l'analyser
il n'y a pas des formations de prix à
l'île maurice par exemple pour la
réunion les pieds depuis need of change
les prix sont faits à maurice il arrive
à la réunion un niveau x plus n
et après quand vous allez discuter la
possibilité de baisser le coût de la vie
on vous dit monsieur regarder le prix
auquel nous avons acheté mais acheter ou
avec ti c'est pour ça je pense que ces
états généraux
doivent être l'occasion d'une
radioscopie du menu qui nous ait des
problèmes des mots que révèlent les
problèmes parce que la révolte qui s'est
fait en guadeloupe aux antilles à divers
degrés dans les quatre dom plus ou moins
c'est pas une révolte superficiel c'est
qu'on a vu aussi après la révolte des
gens criaient vive la république
donc ils se reconnaissent dans le moule
mais estime que la république laisse se
perpétue et d injustice et je pense que
la première injustice qui est mal vécu
bien sûr c'est le coût de la vie c'est
ce qui touche tous les jours à la vie
quotidienne et à la vie familiale
mais la raison la plus profonde c'est
que les jeunes qui constituent notre
avenir non plus l'avenir et ça voyez
vous je l' ai entendu par la télévision
de la bouche de toutes les mères de
familles qui sont exprimés en guadeloupe
au moment de la révolte
tout le monde a dit mais moi mon enfant
il n'a plus d'avenir
et là je pense qu'il faut faire une
radioscopie du système scolaire
outre-mer c'est le système national
qu'on a plaqué outre mer au lieu
d'adapter un système à la culture locale
à la langue locale à la l'environnement
local
chez nous par exemple l'arbre c'est un
chêne il n'ya pas de chaîne à la réunion
il ya des filaos et pendant longtemps on
a dit l'arbre est un boulot mais pour
nous le boulot ce travail oui c'est tous
ces chocs culturels qui ont fait que
aujourd'hui en un système qui ne
valorise pas l'atout jeunesse je vais
pas développer plus long j'aurais voulu
avoir votre avis si en tant que préfet
investi par le président de la
république de cette mission de lui
éminemment très important pour l'avenir
nos départements nous allons aller à la
recherche des causes offrandes des maux
dont nous souffrons et bien sûr après
diagnostic évalué
les meilleurs remèdes pour en sortir
voilà ma question monsieur sénateurs
alioune avez vous noté que pendant votre
intervention mes épaules se sont
affaissées parce que l'analyse que vous
faisiez me donner le sentiment que la
responsabilité qui sera la nôtre
pendant cette période de réflexion sera
considérable elle nous concerne au
premier chef ça c'est bien évident mais
en l'occurrence ce que nous aurons à un
visage et c'est au fond du du des
réponses de long terme mais des réponses
parfois de très long terme qui sont de
nature à stabiliser nos collectivités ou
au contraire à donner le sentiment que
nous n'avons pas été à la hauteur des
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui dans les responsabilités
respectives des uns et des autres alors
bien évidemment bien évidemment la
première démarche qui sera la nôtre sera
de d'établir ce bilan de la situation et
on n'évitera pas de se poser la question
d'un stand de cause la question de
l'inadaptation de l'organisation
actuelle par seulement politique choix
que nous ne ferions une erreur si nous
nous contentions de dire il y a
simplement une question statutaire à
régler la question des prix et pose
manière évidente celle de l'organisation
de l'administration de l'économie avec
une responsabilité pour répondre à une
question précédente
une deuxième fois à une responsabilité
de l'état dire que nous aurons à nous
poser la question du rôle régulateur de
l'état en matière de bruit des
dispositifs qui sont de nature à veiller
à ce que les normes applicables sont
bien respectés et le cas échéant si le
respect des règles de concurrence n'ont
pas permis de le faire
le la capacité de sanctionner des
comportements qui sont erratiques où ils
sont anormaux mais nous ne pourrons pas
à cause de la responsabilité que vous
avez pointé du doigt et qui sera la
nôtre
aux autres ne pourront pas nous arrêter
aux causes l'on attend de nous que nous
fassions émerger à cette occasion avec
cet instant de réflexion solidaire
collectif des propositions qui seraient
susceptibles de garantir et je partage
tout à fait votre analyse que cette
jeunesse ne se sentent pas aujourd'hui
désarmé en face de l'avenir et par froid
quel que soit son niveau de formation y
est juste pour dire que concernant la
radioscopie je vois que c'est plus haut
à la mission de la faire non pas que le
temps qu'ils étaient partis soient forme
limitée
et puis d'autres nous a parlé de la
jeunesse je crois c'est véritablement un
point commun que nous avons dans les
outre-mer et les jeunes quittaient
sweetback cas de la martinique comme
certainement guadeloupe il avait un
monocle de nos futurs pas d'avenir
no future la proximité de la d2 unis
certainement mais pas seulement cela
mais il nous reste plus qu à vous
remercier monsieur le délégué général et
pour tous ces éléments que vous a
apporté ce soir lorsque temps vous
raconter plus certainement très souvent
pour que nous confrontons nos analyses
et des soumissions à venir pour le
public grand bien de nos populations
vous venez de suivre la première
audition de la mission d'information du
sénat sur l'autre au maire je vous
rappelle qu'un des objectifs de cette
mission est d'accompagner les états
généraux de l'outre-mer vous pourrez la
revoir sur notre site internet
www.publicsenat.fr
merci de votre fidélité et à très
bientôt sur notre antenne
à